णमो अरिहंताणं णमो सिद्धाणं
णमो आयरियाणं णमो उवज्झायाणं
णमो लोए सव्व साहूणं नमः समयसाराय
स्वानुभूत्या चकासते । चित्स्वभावाय भावाय
सर्वभावान्तरच्छिदे परित्यज्य। मंगलं भगवान वीरो,
मंगलं गौतमो गणी। मंगलं कुन्दकुन्दार्यो,
जैनधर्मोऽस्तु मंगलम्॥ सर्वमङ्गलमाङ्गल्यं
सर्वकल्याणकारकम। प्रधानं सर्वधर्माणां
जैनं जयति शासनम॥ ॐकारबिन्दुसंयुक्तं
नित्यं ध्यायन्ति योगिनः। कामदं मोक्षदं चैव
ॐकाराय
नमो नमः श्री
द्रव्य दृष्टि प्रकाश।
पूज्य निहालचंद जी सौगानी
जी के आध्यात्मिक पत्र। पत्र। पत्र 17 राज इष्ट। चौथा
लिख रहे हैं। तत्र।
सुबह चला था वहां से आगे लेते हैं। अपने परमात्मा के
चौघड़ी की तारीफ करते हैं। कहते हैं कि।
हरेक। अरे भगवान नारायण परमात्मा। तेरे दर्शन होते ही।
विभाव की पीठ दिखने लगती है।
तेरा यथार्थ भान हुए बिना। भान तो हुआ था शास्त्र पढ़ पढ़ के। आत्मा है सब।
वो कोई यथार्थ भान नहीं हुआ। उसमें बीच में।
दूसरों की help ली गई थी। Help ली गई। शास्त्र से। या गुरु वाणी से।
जब स्वयं या अपने ज्ञान के द्वारा अंतर्मुख होकर के अपने भगवान का अनुभव किया।
तो वो यथार्थवान हुआ। जब तक
स्वयं अपने ज्ञान से अंतर्मुख होकर के अपने भगवान के दर्शन नहीं कर पाए। तब तक।
चाहे जितनी अच्छी जानकारी हो। अपने स्वरूप के बारे में।
तो भी वो यथार्थवान नहीं हो सकता। यथार्थ भान नहीं होता।
तेरा यथार्थ भान हुए
बिना जब तक अंतर्मुख दृष्टि की
नहीं, स्वयं ने अपने परमात्मा का अनुभव
किया नहीं, तब तक, पूर्व में यानी भूतकाल में,
परिणाम आश्रित परिणामों का,
आत्मा आश्रित नहीं, परिणामों आश्रित। आत्मा आश्रित और परिणाम आश्रित में क्या
फर्क है? परिणाम आश्रित माने मुझे ध्यान करना है।
और आत्मा आश्रित माने क्या? मुझे ध्यान नहीं करना है।
मैं तो ध्यान का विषय हूँ। Clear?
फर्क है बहुत। अपने को लगता है दोनों equal हैं। मुझे आत्मा का ध्यान करना है।
एक बात एक sentence में ये है कि मुझे ध्यान करना
है, ध्यान करना है, ध्यान करना है। कि उपयोग बाहर क्यों जाता है, अंदर लेके आओ,
अंदर लेके आओ। तो उपयोग बाहर रहना अच्छा नहीं लगता है।
और चाहते हैं कि हम उपयोग हमारा अंदर हो।
इसमें क्या होता है कि उपयोग जो बाहर है उसके ऊपर द्वेष है।
और उपयोग जो अंदर आएगा उसके प्रति राग है। या राग द्वेष हो गए।
संसार में किधर भी रुचि नहीं है।
अगर पहले जहाँ जहाँ गुस्सा आता था, क्रोध, मान, माया, लोभ होता था,
वहाँ भी अब अवलोकन के
प्रयोग से मुझे कहीं भी राग, द्वेष नहीं हो रहा। पहले तो
थोड़ा कुछ बोले तो गुस्सा आया,
अब तो गालियाँ की बरसात करे ना,
तो भी
मेरे को मन में भी गुस्सा नहीं आता। ये अवलोकन के साथ। तो बाहर के राग, द्वेष
छूट गए और शरीर में भी कुछ... राग द्वेष छूट गए
और शरीर में भी कुछ होवे तो मुझे परवाह नहीं अब।
पहले थोड़ा भी कुछ होवे तो परवाह होती थी।
अब अवलोकन की साधना से आत्मा की रुचि इतनी बढ़ गई, कि कुछ भी हो जाए,
कुछ शरीर की सुध बुद्धि नहीं रहती।
धूम चढ़ गई है आत्म कल्याण की। धूम चढ़ गई आत्म दर्शन कब होगा कब होगा। तो
और जगह से रुचि हट गई।
तो और जगह राग द्वेष होता ही नहीं।
लेकिन कहाँ फंसा? कहाँ फँसा? आकाश के आकाश से गिरा ना,
तो खजूर पे लटका। क्या?
सब clear कर दिया, कहीं राग द्वेष नहीं हो रहे।
ना समाज का डर, ना कुटुंब परिवार का problem, ना शरीर में कहीं ममत्व भाव।
नहीं ढेर सारे विकल्प संकल्प।
एक ही विकल्प रहा, मुझे
आत्मदर्शन करना है बस और कुछ नहीं चाहिए। मुझे सिर्फ शांति चाहिए और मेरा को
जल्दी से जल्दी आत्मा... और मेरा को जल्दी से जल्दी आत्मा का दर्शन
करना है। ढेर सारे संकल्प विकल्प ऐसा करूँ कि वैसा करूँ इधर जाऊँ तो
उधर जाऊँ ऐसा खत्म हो गया।
बिल्कुल line clear है। अब राग द्वेष का कोई अवकाश नहीं लेकिन फिर कहाँ?
कहीं नहीं तो यहाँ फँसा कहाँ? मेरा उपयोग बाहर क्यों है? उससे द्वेष।
और मेरा उपयोग अंदर आवे तो अच्छा इसका नाम दाव।
कहीं राग द्वेष नहीं किया तो
इधर। कहीं रास नृत्य नहीं किया तो इधर किया। बाका से गिरा और खजूर
पे लटका आखिर बात वही की वही।
इसका नाम है परिणाम आश्रित परिणामों का।
परिणाम आश्रित परिणाम चक्कर में फंस गए। वो अभिमन्यु को क्या था?
वो चक्रव्यूह था ना उसमें घुसना तो आता था।
लेकिन बाहर निकलना नहीं आता था ये ऐसा फंस गया
है। सबको हटा दिया। सबको हटा दिया समाज को,
कुटुंब को, अपने शरीर को, ढेर सारे संकल्प भी कर लिए। decision ले लिया।
मर जाऊं तो बेहतर है लेकिन मुझे आत्मदर्शन नहीं करना। decision ले लिया।
उसे अगर अपना उपयोग आ
जाता है तो अच्छा
नहीं लगता। पर ऐसा नहीं करके कि इसको फाड़ के फेंक दो। नहीं। जानना है
उसको उपयोग कहां है। बाहर, जान।
अंदर आऊं, अंदर आऊं ऐसा ये ये परिणाम आसे थे। बाहर क्यों? परिणाम से तो। बाहर
क्यों बाहर क्यों अंदर क्यों नहीं
ये सब परिणाम से। नहीं जो भी जैसा भी हो रहा है जानना है।
जानने में रहे तो कुछ नहीं लेकिन जानने के साथ कर्तृत्व भाव है तो problem है।
क्या? कर्तृत्व भाव नहीं होना है। तो।
सब देखो clear हो गया ना अब यहाँ फँस गया। चक्रव्यूह में घुस तो गया और सबको हटा दिया
लेकिन खुद बाहर निकल नहीं पाया।
आत्मज्ञान नहीं होगा। ये यथार्थ ज्ञान नहीं होने का कारण है।
भूतकाल में अपने स्वरूप को भूल करके, बहुत गोते लगाए।
यहां तक कि सद्गुरुदेव मिल गए। साक्षात तीर्थंकर भगवान के समूहन शरण में गए।
सारी गलतियां मिटा दी। कौन सी? पर पदार्थ में मोह,
समाज का समाज में मोह, परिवार में मोह,
शरीर में मोह, ये सब। शरीर में मोह ये सब निकाल दिए।
आत्मकल्याण भी करना है और संसार में थोड़ा ये भी करना है वो भी मिटा दिए
एक ही बात रह गई कौन सी?
आत्मकल्याण ही करना है दूसरा कुछ
नहीं करना है। अब तो line clear है ना? अफ़सा। का
मेरा उपयोग बाहर रहता है वो ठीक नहीं है जल्दी से
अंदर आ जावे तो
अच्छा। क्या? सम्यक दर्शन करना
है सम्यक दर्शन। सम्यक दर्शन करना है, सम्यक दर्शन, सम्यक दर्शन। सम्यक दर्शन की value
इतनी बड़ी हो गई कि आत्मा इतना हो गया है छोटा। क्या?
सम्यक दर्शन की value ज्यादा नहीं है,
आत्मा की value ज्यादा है। कि विकल्प मेरा पीछा नहीं छोड़ते हैं।
क्या? ये तो ऐसी बात हो गई खंभे को पकड़ लिया और फिर बोलता है खंभा मुझे
नहीं छोड़ता है। वो विकल्प फटे तो निरिक्ख ध्यान होवे ना, लेकिन क्या
करो विकल्प... ध्यान होवे ना
लेकिन क्या करूँ विकल्प शांत होता
ही नहीं एक को हटाया तो दूसरा आता
है दूसरे को हटाया तीसरा आता है दूसरे कोई विचार
नहीं आते हैं सिर्फ सद्गुरुदेव के विचार उनकी भक्ति के विचार और
जल्दी से आत्मा का दर्शन करो
यही विचार आता है दूसरा कोई विचार नहीं आता विकल्प पर का हो
चाहे स्व का हो विकल्प तो
विकल्प है अपनी मौत है और कुछ नहीं है
अब इतने अच्छे ये नहीं कहे तो क्या करेंगे। ने अच्छा ये नहीं कहा तो क्या करने बोलो?
क्या? आत्मा के विचार नहीं करूँ तो मैं कौन सा करूँ?
ये तो करना ना, ये तो करना माने क्या हो गया?
पहले संसार के विचार में मन का आधार लेता था, अब आत्मा के विचार में मन का आधार
लेता है। आखिर मन का आधार तो लेना चालू रह गया।
इसमें क्या हो गया? पराधीनता हुई कि हुई?
उपयोग तो बाहर जाएगा ही। आत्मदर्शन में मन का आधार भी लेना नहीं है।
सम्यक दर्शन चाहिए ऐसा भी नहीं। तो परिणाम आश्रित हो जाएगा।
तो कहते हैं इधर कि तेरे तेरा यथार्थ भान हुए बिना पूर्व में।
परिणाम आश्रित परिणामों का इतना तीव्र बंध कर चुका था।
परिणाम। परिणाम आश्रित परिणामों का
तीव्र बंद कर चुका था। सम्यक दर्शन चाहिए इसीलिए
चाहता हूँ कि मेरा उपयोग आत्मा में लीन हो जाए।
मुझे जल्दी से आत्मध्यान खोजा है। ये गड़बड़ है बहुत बड़ी।
अब ये बात तो सुने तो फिर हम करना क्या?
पहले ही बोलना था ना कि आत्मध्यान नहीं करना है। पहले तो बोले हाँ भावना करो,
ऐसा करो, ऐसा करो, करो। करो ऐसा करो ऐसा करो
करके लेके आए। अब जब हमने नकी कर लिया सारे विचारों को हटा दिया और एक ही बात रखा
आत्म ध्यान करना। अब आकर के हमको बोलते हो कि भैया आत्म ध्यान ऐसे
नहीं होगा। अब क्या करें हम अब तो
कोई रास्ता ही नहीं बचा ना पीछे जाए तो खाई
आगे बढ़े तो।
कहीं जगह नहीं छोड़ी हमारे। सब छोड़कर के एक ही decision पे
आए तो अभी। अब छोड़ कर के
एक ही decision पे आया तो अभी यहाँ से भी खिसकाना था फिर पाँव ज़मीन पे कहाँ रखे हैं?
पूरा ज़मीन ही निकाल लेते हो नीचे से। कि परिणाम आश्रित परिणामों का...
ये जो
आधार लोगे ना मन का या परिणामों का, ये गलत है।
ये राग द्वेष की बात है। कर्तृत्व भाव है इसके अंदर। बोलो। परिणाम आश्रित
परिणामों पर आश्रय लेना... हाँ वही वही चल रहा है।
बोलो। कर्तृत्व बुद्धि बोल... बुद्धि उसका कर्तृत्व बुद्धि है राग द्वेष है
मेरा उपयोग बाहर है वो नुकसान है उसपे द्वेष आता है।
मैं चाहता हूँ कि मेरा उपयोग बाहर न रहे। मेरा उपयोग अपने
आत्मा में लीन हो जाए। क्या ग्रह? क्या? तो
मेरा उपयोग अंदर में रहे तो सम्यक दर्शन सम्यक दर्शन के ऊपर राग।
और उपयोग बाहर रहता है।
वो मिथ्या दर्शन या राग द्वेष के परिणाम उसके ऊपर द्वेष। हमको
राग द्वेष की परिणति के ऊपर भी द्वेष करना
नहीं है। विकल्प के ऊपर द्वेष करना नहीं है,
निर्विकलता से प्रेम करना नहीं
है। अपन प्यार करे तो।
क्या? नहीं तो निर्विकल निर्विकल्प हो जाना है, निर्विकल्प हो
जाना है। अरे भैया निर्विकलता तेरे से बड़ी चीज़ थोड़ी है,
तू बड़ा है। तुझे निर्विकलता चाहिए कि आत्मा चाहिए?
तुझे interest चाहिए कि main... तुझे interest चाहिए कि main amount चाहिए?
amount निकल गया। नहीं मुझे interest दे दो। फिर आप मांगना नहीं कभी भी।
fixed fixed जो रकम है। नहीं वो तो चाहिए। तो फिर interest काहे को मांगते हो?
दोनों में से important कौन सा है?
interest या मूल? मूल important है क्योंकि मूल जिंदा रहेगा तो
interest भी आएगा। तो interest भी काहे का आएगा? हम लोग
interest की लालच में... हम लोग interest की लालच में, सम्यक दर्शन की लालच में,
अपने आत्मा की value खत्म कर डालते हैं। इसका नाम है परिणाम सहित
परिणाम। यहाँ तक पहुँच गया।
लेकिन ध्यान लगाना है, ध्यान लगाने के चक्कर में भगवान को ही भूल रहे
हैं। भक्ति करना है, भक्ति करना है। लेकिन किसकी? वो मुझे याद नहीं है अब। देखो।
देखो। वो नहीं वो Sholay picture में वो बसंती। मालूम है वो?
मौसी कुछ काम देती है तो
अच्छा मैं करके आता हूँ। वो मेरे बड़बड़ इतनी करती थी। कि वो
जो 5 minute का काम को 2-4 घंटे लग गया। बाद में अरे मौसी ने मुझे ये कहा था
कि जब तक सबसे बड़बड़ करके पूरा...
आखिरी में जा जाता है जब तक तो
पूरा खत्म ना हो। ऐसा हो जाता है कि... ऐसा हो जाता है कि
परमात्मा के पीछे लगते लगते परमात्मा छूट गया और सम्यक दर्शन है उससे लगा हो गया।
क्या? ये problem हो जाता है ये एक फस गया
अंदर घुसा सबको clear किया चक्रव्यूह में।
लेकिन खुद फस गया वापस खुद बाहर नहीं निकल पाया अभी मान लो।
चक्रव्यूह में फस गया। क्या कर्तृत्व भाव है कि मुझे ध्यान करना है।
ये कर्तृत्व भाव माने परिणाम। तो भाव माने परिणाम आश्रित परिणामों का आधार लिया।
तो क्या होना चाहिए? कि मुझे ध्यान करना नहीं है।
वो सब पर्याय का कार्य पर्याय करेगा। मैं तो
ध्यान का विषय हूँ। मैं परमात्मा क्यों पीछे पड़ूँ? मैं परमात्मा हूँ।
मेरा ध्यान पर्याय को
करना है तो करे, नहीं करना है तो कोई बात नहीं, मुझे अपेक्षा नहीं
है। ये है द्रव्य आश्रित। ये द्रव्य आश्रित कार्य पद्धति।
वो एक परिणाम आश्रित कार्य पद्धति। बहुत से लोग कहाँ फंस गए किनारे पे आकर के।
Starting में तो विकल्पों के लिए इसको
आधार लेना है। यहाँ end
की बात चल रही है starting की बात नहीं।
ध्यान। हाँ मेरा। मेरा
ध्यान मैं मैं इधर हूँ।
परमात्मा। अब
उपयोग मतलब उपयोग माने
ज्ञान किया। उपयोग मतलब उपयोग माने ज्ञान की अवस्था। ज्ञान की अवस्था को मेरा ध्यान
परमात्मा को करना है तो करे।
मेरे को कोई अपेक्षा नहीं है कि वो परिणाम उधर रहे कि इधर रहे।
क्या? मैं परमात्मा
एक समय के उपयोग की भीख
नहीं मांगता हूँ कि भैया तुम उधर मत देख इधर देख। देखना है तो देख बाल भटक।
मुझे तेरी परवाह नहीं। मेरा तो
बाल। मेरा तो बाल भी बाका नहीं होता है मैं इधर हूँ तुझे देखना है सुखी होना तो देख
दुखी होना तो जा हट।
मैं ध्यान करने वाला नहीं मैं ध्यान का subject हूँ।
ये important बात है छोटी बात लगती है
लेकिन बहुत बड़ी बात है। अभिप्राय की बहुत बड़ी खोज है। ध्यान के बहाने
भी मुझे ध्यान करना है ऐसे करके भी
सूक्ष्म कर्तृत्व अंदर। सूक्ष्म कर्तृत्व अंदर घुस जाता है
और ज्ञाता दृष्टा भाव टूट जाता है। मैं परमात्मा यहाँ बैठा हूँ।
मुझे कुछ नहीं चाहिए मोक्ष भी नहीं चाहिए। ये रहा मैं आज। मैं तो यही चैतन्य हूँ।
क्या?
उपयोग बाहर है कि अंदर है मुझे
उपयोग को देखना है कि चैतन्य तत्व को देखना है? मुझे उपयोग को देखना है
उपयोग को पलटाना है कि... है उपयोग को पलटाना है कि चैतन्य मैं हूँ ऐसा देखना है।
मुझे उपयोग को नहीं पलटाना। बहुत बड़ी बात। कि पूर्व में परिणामों से
परिणामों का इतना तीव्र बंद कर चुका था।
और इतने कर्म बांध लिए थे। कि उनको खत्म करने के लिए।
तेरे दर्शन स्वाभाविक होने ही थे। करना था नहीं तेरा दर्शन। करना
था नहीं तेरा दर्शन करना
था नहीं। तो करते तो वो आ जाएगा। उनका खत्म होने का time आ गया। तो तेरा दर्शन
तो होना ही था तेरे दर्शन
के बिना कैसे खत्म होते। सहज में ले। सहज सहज। बिना कष्ट करना है ये जो पूरा जो
हमने धर्म
की बातें। ये
आप ऐसा ही गलती कर कर के।
उपयोग के पीछे उपयोग को पलटाने के चक्कर में।
कभी भी मैंने प्रमुख परमात्मा को ध्यान नहीं दिया। फिर
भी मैंने प्रमुख परमात्मा को ध्यान नहीं दिया। तो ये... और विराधना चालू रखी। जो कर्ता
बुद्धि आ रही है हमेशा उसका
ही वर्णन कर रहा हूँ। परिणामों से
परिणामों का तीव्र बंधन कर चुका था। और ढेर सारे कर्म बांध दिए।
अब यहाँ
कर्म बंधन का कारण परद्रव्य नहीं है, समाज
नहीं है, परिवार नहीं है, शरीर नहीं है, संकल्प
विकल्प नहीं है ढेर सारे। यहाँ कर्म बंधन का कारण कौन है? मुझे... बंधन
का कारण कौन है? मुझे
सम्यक दर्शन प्रकट करना है। देखो तो सही। कितनी सूक्ष्म
मूले हैं। इतना भी चलता नहीं है। तब ऐसी
भी भावना नहीं रखना। कि
अब तक क्यों बोले सम्यक दर्शन प्रकट करो।
पहले ही बोलना था। पहले बोलते तो यहाँ तक नहीं आते थे। क्या?
पहले नहीं बोलना है। अभी end में secret पन्ना अभी खोलना है। ये जादू है। अभी खोलना
है। ये जादू है जादू। ये नयों का जादू है।
पहले वो chocolate दिखाना लगा। आओ पीछे आओ पीछे
आओ करके फिर बाद में बोला chocolate कहाँ है?
तो खाली chocolate का cover है। क्या? आखिरी दिन
बोलते। आखिरी दिन बोलते पहले बोलते तो?
इतना हम हैरान हो
गए रात को 2-2 बजे तक जाके। अब बोले
कुछ करना नहीं था। देखो,
कितना सताते हो। कितना सताते हो?
आखरी दिन तक क्यों बोले अभी नहीं बोलना था। अभी भी हम रात भर जागने वाले थे
लेकिन अभी जागना कि
नहीं जागना परेशानी हो गई हमें। अब मेहनत करना कि नहीं करना? देख। अभी कोई
नहीं बैठेगा देखना रात में। ये
परेशानी है बोले तो परेशानी है सम्यक दर्शन के
पीछे हम नहीं भागना मैं परमात्मा हूँ। आना है तो आए सम्यक दर्शन।
क्या वाजपेयी बोलते हो ना सर? आप ही बोलते हो ना sir? ऐसा करके कुछ बोलता है।
लटका करके।
जो एक-एक शब्द आधे-आधे घंटे को नहीं
करता है। आँख बंद करके ऐसा करो। अभी कोई आज ध्यान करने
वाला नहीं है क्योंकि ध्यान तो रहना है तो रहेगा समय तो है। मैं काहे को पीछे पड़ूँ?
मैं तो परमात्मा हूँ।
पक्का tight। अंदर बैठ जाना। हो जाएगा ना अपने आप।
होवे कि नहीं होवे? परिणाम आश्रित जो हमारी आधार बुद्धि
है। परिणाम से जो हमारी आधार बुद्धि
है वो तो छूट जानी चाहिए।
परिणाम का आधार लोगे भी तो तो भी कहाँ होने वाला है बेका कसर खपा लो।
इससे तो better है कि परिणाम की गुलामी छूट जाए।
कम से कम कार्य हो
नहीं हो important नहीं है, परिणामों की गुलामी छूटना बहुत
important है। सम्यक दर्शन नहीं चाहिए मुझे, परमात्मा है,
मुझे नज़र में परमात्मा है। परिणामों की कोई value
नहीं है मेरे नज़र में। परमात्मा की ही value है। परमात्मा की ही value है
और मैं साक्षात परमात्मा हूँ। देखो, एक बहुत
important thing है। कल मंत्र
दिया था ना सौगानी जी ने अनुभव
करने का।
क्या दिया था? प्रदेशे प्रदेशे। मैं मात्र चैतन्य चैतन्य भाव आनंद
आनंद से
ओतप्रोत वस्तु। सम्यक दर्शन चाहिए ये बात कहाँ से? सम्यक दर्शन चाहिए ये बात कहाँ थी?
प्रकट करने की बात कहाँ थी?
प्रकट कुछ भी नहीं करना। जाना है कि मैं परमात्मा हूँ। That's all.
सम्यक दर्शन अपने आप आ जाएगा पीछे-पीछे। सम्यक दर्शन क्या केवल ज्ञान आ जाएगा?
फिर बोलेगा नहीं मुझे नहीं जाना है मोक्ष में।
अब नहीं चलेगा। पहले ही बोला था ना सोच लेना।
आत्मा का दर्शन करने से
पहले decide कर लेना। क्या करना है। पहले decide कर लेना तुम क्या करना है।
फिर दर्शन करने के बाद बोलो कि मुझे मोक्ष में नहीं जाना है, ये impossible है।
तुमको उठा करके टिंगा टोड़ी करके लेके है मोक्ष। देखो।
बहुत जबरदस्त मर्म है इसके अंदर, परिणामाश्रित परिणामों का तीव्र बंध कर चुका था।
यहाँ परद्रव्य में नहीं फँसाया, राग द्वेष परद्रव्य में नहीं कराया।
समाज ने नहीं करा है। परिवार ने नहीं करा है। शरीर ने नहीं करा है।
संकल्प विकल्प ने नहीं कराया। यहाँ राग द्वेष किसके कारण से हुए?
कि मुझे सम्यक दर्शन प्रकट करो।
निर्विकल्लता की चाह में विकल्प विकल्प विकल्प करते गए। निर्विकल्लता की
चाह। और बांधते गए अपने को। तीव्र बंध कर
चुका था। बंद कर चुका था।
उनकी अवधि खत्म होने के लिए। उन सभी सारे बंधन को
बंधन से छुटकारा लेने के लिए। तेरा दर्शन स्वाभाविक होना ही था।
करना था नहीं करूंगा ऐसा नहीं होना ही था। इसलिए आत्मा का अनुभव करना है तो क्या करना?
मेरा उपयोग अंदर आ जाए
कि नहीं उपयोग की गुलामगिरी मत करना भैया। मैं प्रदेश से प्रदेश से
मात्र। ऐसे प्रदेश है मात्र चैतन्य चैतन्य और आनंद आनंद की मूर्ति हूँ बस इतना ही।
मेरा उपयोग बाहर क्यों है अंदर कब आए
वो सब पंचायत नहीं करनी। ये भी विकल्प हो गया। शुरू में है
बाद में भाव में बिठा दो। और 4 point पहले विकल्प को काम दे दो।
मैं चैतन्य मूर्ति हूँ।
सुख दुख की जो भी अवस्था है उसको
सहन कर। फिर ये मन record बजाता है। ये मन record बजाता है मैं तो यही हूँ
मैं तो इसको भी गौण करूँ।
और फिर ज्ञान में बिठा दो कि मैं तो यही हूँ। That's all.
मेरा उपयोग अंदर आ जाए ऐसी
भिखारी बना नहीं करना करो। सुबह आई थी ना बात भिखारी को
मोक्ष की सुंदरी वरमाला
नहीं पहनाती। सम्यक दर्शन की भीख मांगने वाले।
कि
मेरे पास अभी तो नौकरी कर रहा हूँ
लेकिन तुम... अभी तो नौकरी कर रहा हूँ लेकिन तुम
है ना करोड़पति की बेटी दहेज में लेके आना सब कुछ। क्या?
सब हो जाएगा।
तुम्हारे बाप को दूसरा कोई है तो
है नहीं कोई लड़का तो है नहीं मैं गर्दामाद बन जाऊँगा।
क्या? देखो खूबसूरत तो हूँ पढ़ा लिखा तो हूँ
मेरे पास पैसा नहीं धंधा नहीं करता हूँ तो क्या होगा?
क्या होगा? क्या होगा? क्या शादी करेगी वो लड़की?
तेरे से छप्पन आएँगे, काला चलेगा, गोरा, गोरा नहीं होगा तो भी चलेगा।
क्या? लेकिन खुद के पैर से कमाया हुआ चाहिए।
ऐसा नहीं चाहिए, भिखारी नहीं चाहिए। जो मेरे पैसों से रहे।
परमात्मा ऐसा नहीं चाहिए, देखो कैसी बात है। सम्यक दर्शन का भिखारी को
सम्यक दर्शन कभी होता नहीं। नहीं। सम्यक दर्शन की पर्याय
उसके गले में भरमाला डालती है, जो सम्यक दर्शन की care भी नहीं करता है।
अपने परमात्मा की जिसको महिमा होती है,
उसके गले में भरमाला होती है। क्या अजीब अजीब है
बिल्कुल। परिणाम आश्रित परिणामों का
इतना तीव्र बंध कर चुका था,
कि उनकी अवधि खत्म होने के लिए, एक...
के कारण परमात्मा भगवान तेरा
दर्शन स्वाभाविक होना ही था।
कितना ये कितना wording कितना है। ये कैसे शब्द मिले होंगे उनको?
कैसे लिखे होंगे ये? अरे चैतन्य वापस अभी तारीफ कम नहीं कर रहे।
चैतन्य की तारीफ करना हो तो इनसे सीखो। कितनी तारीफ। अरे चैतन्य
देखो अनुभव करते हैं ना। अरे चैतन्य
तेरी इतनी चौड़ाई। विस्मित सा कर देती है। है तो 5 foot के अंदर ही।
इसमें लंबा ऐसा ऊंचा ज्यादा है। Area आत्मा। 5 feet 3 inch।
मेरी height बता रहा हूँ। क्या? चौड़ाई किधर है?
चौड़ाई तो है नहीं। अगर इसको
चौड़ाई करते हो तो कितना होगा? पढ़ाई करते हो तो कितना
होगा ये बोल बोलना? 18 inch maximum. और ऐसा देखो तो,
तीन चार inch या छह inch
maximum. 6 by 18 by 5 by 3 inch. क्या?
ऐसा हिसाब किताब है? ये भगवान का माप।
तेरा माप कितना देवचंद भाई
का? 5 foot ऊंचाई कितनी है? 5 feet 3 inch. और ब्रह्मा... आत्मा की
नहीं। और परमात्मा का माप कितना है?
क्यों नीलकंठों में माप थोड़ा होता है? तो असंख्य प्रदेश ही है।
और जब वहाँ दृष्टि जमती है ना।
जब इसमें दृष्टि जमती है तो क्या होता है? इसकी बात करते हैं। गजब के
wording है इनके पास। अरे चैतन्य
तेरी इतनी पोंलाई विस्मय सा कर देती है,
आश्चर्यजनक। आश्चर्यजनक। ऐसा लगता है
पूरी दुनिया में दूसरा कोई है ही नहीं अंदर गया तो।
कितना फैल चुका? आप हिसाब लगाते हो? कितना फैल गया?
आकाश में परमात्मा ऐसा नहीं, इतने बड़े आकाश में
परमात्मा ऐसा नहीं, आकाश दिखता ही नहीं है। देखिए। अंदर गए तो
क्या दिखता है? चैतन्य प्रदेश में क्या दिखता है?
आकाश ही नहीं दिखता है।
असल में क्या है? दिखता है। असल में क्या है बाहर के area से देखा जाए तो
आकाश अनंत प्रदेशी है और ये भगवान आत्मा चैतन्य असंख्य प्रदेशी।
असल में तो ये है। और इस body का जो माप है वो हिसाब है।
इसके अंदर है।
लेकिन अंदर जब नजर करते
ठहर जाते हैं ना निर्विकल्प भाव में। आकाश छोटा पड़। फिर कितना
फैल चुका है ये व्यापक।
इतना व्यापक हो गया है। कि। है।
कि सारी दुनिया बिंदु जैसा भी नहीं दिखती है। दुनिया दिखती ही नहीं है।
क्या? दुनिया ही नहीं दिखती है। ये बाजू में शरीर नहीं दिखता
है। ये जोर से आवाज आ रही है तो वो कान में नहीं घुस जा रही अब।
क्यों नहीं घुस जा रही अब? उपयोग कहाँ चले गया? परमात्मा के साथ mix हो
गया। तो पोलाई माने?
ऐसा। ये पोलाई। ये पोलाई। तेरी इतनी सा
ज्यादा पोलाई dismiss सा कर देती
है। आश्चर्यजनक, मैं समझा था कि इतना होंगी पोलाई।
अंदर गया तो... अंदर देखा तो क्या हो?
दूसरा कुछ दिखता ही नहीं। नहीं तो ऐसा हो ना इसके
बाद फिर ये है, इसके बाद ये है। मैं तो
इतने में हूँ। मतलब बाहर का area के अंदर मैं इतने में हूँ।
अंदर जब देखा तो बाहर का कुछ दिखता नहीं है, मैं ही मैं ही
दिखता हूँ। कुछ दिखता नहीं है मैं ही मैं ही दिखता हूँ। क्या हुआ मैया?
Width width कितनी है width? ये बात कहते
हैं। अरे चैतन्य तेरी इतनी भोलाई विस्मित सा कर देती है।
और ऐसा निर्विकल्प अनुभव होता है तो गुरु की याद तो कैसे भी आ जाती
है। इतना बड़ा परमात्मा हमको दे दिया। क्या?
इसकी कल्पना भी हमने नहीं की थी। भगवान क्या पावन... भगवान
क्या पामर मानते थे अपने को। और क्या से क्या बना दिया।
पामरता तो कहाँ चली गई और भगवान बन गए।
तो गुरु को कैसे भूल सकते हैं। तो चैतन्य की महिमा हुई।
अंदर उपयोग गया चैतन्य की महिमा हुई
फौरन next word किसका आया। गुरुदेव का हे गुरुदेव। आप
कितनी पौरुष तक प्रसर चुके हो।
अरे अंदर तो आत्मा दिखता है गुरुदेव। अरे हमने तो आत्मा दिखता है गुरुदेव
कहाँ है? कि नहीं गुरुदेव
के बिना ये संभव नहीं था।
मैं तो गुरुदेव को यहाँ बिठा करके रखा था।
पहले क्या बोलता है चैतन्य फोड़ा है बाद में क्या बोले?
हे गुरुदेव आप मेरी आत्मा में कितना फैल चुके हो। कि जनम जनम तक ना भूलूँगा।
ये उपकार तुम्हारा देखो। ऐसी भक्ति करूँ प्रभु जी
मिले ना जन्मम। मिले
ना जन्म। ये बात है। ये अकेले कैसे जाए? डर लगता था।
मिलेगा कि नहीं मिलेगा, क्या होगा?
गुरु ने बोला, समय से संकु
किक मार। ऐसा कैसा? मैं बोलता हूँ ना मार। अच्छा भाई, नहीं चाहिए।
किसके सहारे जाता है अब?
सतगुरु के सहारे जाता है। सतगुरु बोलता है, तुम आगे चल, मैं पीछे-पीछे आता हूँ। फिर
वो... आगे चला। देखो पीछे मुड़ के नहीं
देखने। देखो पीछे मुड़ के नहीं देखना। अच्छी बात है, आगे
जाता हूँ। आप पीछे रहना। हाँ मैं हूँ ना पीछे।
मैं हूँ ना। तो गया वो अंदर।
और गुरु ने चालाकी कर दी। जैसे वो दरवाजे के अंदर गया कि वो दरवाजे पे खड़े हो।
क्या? ताकि ये खड़े रहे कि बाहर से
कोई अंदर नहीं घुस जाए। और अभी सम्यक दर्शन चाहिए ऐसी बात ना आ जाए।
वहाँ खड़े रह के दरवाजे के पास। वो अकेला गया अंदर। वो क्या समझा गुरु है पीछे मेरे।
तो असल में गुरु ने चालाकी की थी। क्योंकि वहां किसी का प्रवेश ही नहीं अंदर में।
लेकिन इसके मगज में ऐसा है कि गुरु मेरे साथ पीछे पीछे आ रहे हैं। लेकिन क्या
करूं मुझे पीछे मुड़ने को मना किया है।
पीछे देखता तो मालूम पड़ जाता कि गुरु ने चालाकी की है।
पीछे मुड़ने को तो मना कर दिया है अब क्या करें?
तो पहला पहला शब्द क्या लिया? अरे चैतन्य... अरे चैतन्य
तेरी इतनी पोलाई विस्मय सा कर देती है। हे गुरुदेव
आप कितनी पोलाई तक
कसर चुके हो? देखो। और देखो
कमाल की बात पोलाई भी है और ठोसपना भी है।
पोला नहीं है। ना वो
फुगा है ना फुगा। फुगा। दाने में बैठते हैं।
फुगा फुगे को संभल तोड़ो। बलून बलून। balloon balloon।
क्या? ओसा खुला हो तो इतना बड़ा तो हो
जाता है। लेकिन अंदर में कुछ नहीं दम नहीं रहता है।
तोड़ा रहता है। ऐसा कोला नहीं है। भरचक है। प्रदेशे प्रदेशे।
प्रदेशे प्रदेशे में मात्र चेतन चेतन
व आनंद आनंद से ओतप्रोत वस्तु को।
कैसी? जरा अंदर
चले गए। जरा अंदर चले
गए अंदर। digest नहीं हुआ। जरा
सुबह बोलके तो
ये हुंकारा मिला। कितनी जबरदस्त बात
है। हे गुरुदेव आप कितनी पगलई तक पसर चुके हो। पगलई भी है। पॉलाई भी है
और साथ में ठोसपना भी है।
ऐसा नहीं है कि वो rubber का टुकड़ा इतना छोटा सा दिया था
इधर एक इधर बीच में कुछ नहीं। नहीं नहीं हर जगह है।
चैतन्य चैतन्य चैतन्य आनंद
हर जगह। इतना फैल चुके हैं इतना फैल चुके हैं। पॉलाई भी है
साथ ही ठोसपना भी। हे गुरुदेव अब गुरुदेव को याद... गुरुदेव अब गुरुदेव
को याद करता है वापस। ये तो ये समझा था कि
मेरे साथ में और मेरे साथ में प्रसर चुके हैं ये पराभौतिक के कारण। क्योंकि गुरु को
अकेले जाने में डर लगता था गुरु को साथ दिया।
गुरु बोले तू आगे चल मैं पीछे पीछे ही हूँ देख।
क्या धोखा दिया गुरु ने। उसको धक्का मार दिया अंदर। धुबकी लगा तू मैं अंदर।
उसको मालूम नहीं उसको तो ऐसा लगा कि पीछे पीछे आ रहे हैं। तो पहले
पूरा चैतन्य फैल गया बाद में बोला गुरुदेव। चैतन्य फैल गया है बाद में बोले
गुरुदेव आप कितना फैल चुके हो।
और कितना खुशपना भी है।
क्या? मतलब निर्विकल्प अनुभूति में स्वाद मिल रहा है, अतिंद्रिय आनंद आ रहा हो।
अब thanks बोलने के लिए वापस पीछे मुड़ के देखता है। क्या? अब अब देखता है बाहर
उपयोग आ रहा है। क्या बोलता है?
ये ये आनंद मिला मुझे परमात्मा का। परमात्मा का
स्पर्श हुआ। मैं ही... मैं ही परमात्मा हूँ ऐसी अनुभूति
हुई। सम्यक दर्शन तो अपने आप उत्पन्न हो गए।
मैं मांगने नहीं गया था मैं तो परमात्मा में लीन था।
मैं ही परमात्मा हूँ ऐसा ऐसा देखो। सम्यक दर्शन हो जाए तो
ऐसा परिणामाश्रित कार्य नहीं किया मैंने।
सम्यक दर्शन हो जाए तो अच्छा ध्यान हो जाए तो ऐसा भीख मंगाना नहीं किया
मैं ही परमात्मा हूँ ऐसा बैठ गया।
थोड़ी देर में उपवन अंदर जमते ही सम्यक दर्शन अपने आप हो गए।
आनंद आनंद हो गए। यहाँ पूरा फैल चुका है पूरी दुनिया में जैसे मैं ही हूँ।
तो मेरे को लगा कि चैतन्य फैल गया है और साथ में गुरुदेव भी फैल गए
हैं। इतना बड़ा area है आपका सर्वव्यापक। ऐसा आश्चर्य।
और फिर ठोसपना भी। ये अनुभव करने के बाद ऐसा भाव आया।
गुरु को thanks बोलने के लिए हाथ मिलाओ। पैर पड़ने के लिए गया। क्या बोलता है?
कि हे गुरु। कि हे गुरुदेव आपकी वाणी का स्पर्श होते ही
मानो विश्व की उत्तमोत्तम वस्तु की प्राप्ति हो गई। वो ठेठ बोलने के लिए बोल रहा
है। ठीक। ये ये कैसे हो गया ये चमत्कार कैसे हुआ? ये अपने वश की बात नहीं थी। ये किसका
उपकार? गुरुदेव का उपकार। क्या उपकार किया? कुछ किया क्या
अंदर में जादू? कुछ नहीं किया। उनके वचन हमारी
आत्मा में... उनके
वचन हमारी आत्मा
में घुस गए। 10 feet का फासला था।
क्या? वो आप तो 25 feet पे चले गए उधर। उधर बैठे।
mic की आवाज़ वहाँ पहुँच जाती है। mic के माध्यम से। किसकी आवाज़? गुरु की आवाज़।
और क्या किया? तद भी नहीं किया है गुरुदेव।
लेकिन उनकी अमृत वाणी mic के द्वारा गूंजते हुए 10-20 feet पे पड़े थे
वहाँ पहुँच गई। हमारी कानों में जाकर के यहाँ से नहीं निकली।
बुद्धि में नहीं बैठी। नड़े में नहीं आत्मा में प्रसर गई।
देखो ये बात कहते हैं। ये वाणी आत्मा में घुस गई।
क्या कहते हैं?
कि हे गुरुदेव आपकी वाणी का स्पर्श आपका स्पर्श नहीं। आपने जो
अंदर चैतन्य में अनुभव किया है।
वो... मन में से फिर वाणी में से फिर mic में से मेरे तक आई कान तक।
वहाँ से सीधा अंदर में कहाँ तक पहुँची?
मेरे आत्मा तक पहुँची। अंदर प्रवेश कर ली।
आपकी वाणी का स्पर्श होते ही...
स्पर्श ये आत्मा का विषय है। सुनना ये कर्णेंद्रिय है। कर्णेंद्रिय।
आपकी वाणी का स्पर्श होते ही क्या हुआ? मानो... क्या हुआ मानो
विश्व की उत्तमोत्तम वस्तु की प्राप्ति हो गई
दुनिया की सबसे सुंदर वस्तु मैं स्वयं परमात्मा मुझे मिल गया।
ये किसका किसका उपकार है आपकी वाणी का उपकार है। आपकी वाणी में वो जादू है
कि सोई हुई चेतना जागृत हो गई। परमात्मा स्वयं को भूल गया था
इतनी सी गलती थी और अनंत काल से। थी और अनंत काल से चौरासी के चक्कर में भटक रहा था।
आपकी वाणी मिलते ही परमात्मा जागा, उसको पता चल गया
परमात्मा कहीं मंदिर में नहीं है, कहीं गुरु के पास नहीं है,
परमात्मा तो मैं स्वयं हूँ। प्राप्ति हो गई।
विश्व की सर्वोत्तम वस्तु मैं
स्वयं परमात्मा हूँ, ये उसको
पता चल गया, अनुभव
में आ गई वो बात। अनुभव होते
ही क्या हुआ?
अब हमको लगा,
क्या लगता है? क्या मैं मुक्त होने वाला हूँ? देखो परमात्मा को देखा तो क्या हुआ?
क्या मैं मुक्त होने वाला हूँ? ऐसा हुआ। अरे,
शास्त्रों में जिस मुक्ति की इतनी महिमा बखानी है... क्या?
जन्म मरण से छूटना कोई
मामूली बात नहीं है, बहुत बड़ी बात है। अनंत काल से नहीं हो वो कार्य।
शास्त्रों में, परमागमों में उसकी बहुत value है मुक्ति की।
अरे शास्त्रों में जिस मुक्ति की इतनी महिमा बखानी है,
उसे आपके शब्द मात्र ने इतना सरल कर दिया।
आपकी वाणी में वो जादू है कि मोक्ष जो बड़े-बड़े त्यागियों
को नहीं मिलता। जो बड़े-बड़े त्यागियों को नहीं मिलता है।
बड़े-बड़े शास्त्र पाठियों को नहीं मिलता है। क्या कितने लोग हमारे यहाँ भूखे प्यासे
तपस्या करते हैं उनको नहीं मिलता है।
और हमको हमारे घर में आकर के मिल गया।
कि इतनी महंगी चीज़ इतनी सस्ती? क्या मैं मुक्त होने वाला हूँ?
मुझे यकीन नहीं आता ये सपना है।
ये सपना लगता है मेरे को। मैंने कभी सपने में सोचा नहीं था।
कि मेरा ये इतने 6 गज की बस्ती में सब लोग अपने आत्मा को
देखे बिना भटक रहे हैं, राजवेश कर रहे हैं।
उसमें से किस कितने लोगों में से मेरा number आएगा और मुझे आत्मा का अनुभव होगा।
मैं कहीं ढूंढने नहीं गया था सद्गुरुदेव। क्या?
सद्गुरुदेव स्वयं... सद्गुरुदेव स्वयं आ गए। और उनकी वाणी सुनी।
और सीधा अंदर में चले गए।
और क्या हुआ ये चमत्कार हो
गया। क्या मैं मुक्त होने वाला हूँ? हाँ परमात्मा मिले फिर मुक्त ही हो जाना।
परमात्मा के दर्शन होते ही
अनंत अनुबंदी के राग द्वेष क्रोध मान माया लोक।
जो मुक्ति के राह में सबसे बड़े कांटे थे दर्शन मोह मिथ्यात्व खत्म हो गए जड़ कट गई।
अब तो मुक्ति निश्चित है।
ज्यादा से ज्यादा 15 bomb। अभी तो दाढ़ी पत्ते हैं चरित्र के वो खत्म होने हैं।
क्या मैं मुक्त होने वाला हूँ? अरे शास्त्रों में जिस मुक्ति की इतनी महिमा वखानी है,
उसे आपके शब्द मात्र ने इतना सरल कर दिया।
सीख अब आगे। क्या विश्व में और भी कुछ चाहना बाकी रह गई?
परमात्मा मिलने के बाद क्या चाहिए? चलो तुमको मैं स्वर्ग में लेके जाऊँ।
चलो मैं तुझे इंद्र पद पे दे दूँ, इंद्रासन पे बैठना। क्या बोलेगा ये जीव
जिसको परमात्मा ने देखा है? परमात्मा को जिसने देख लिया है? क्या बोलेगा?
क्या बोलेगा? चाहिए स्वर्ग? तीन लोक का राज चाहिए?
मैं हूँ एक शुद्ध सदारूपी ज्ञान दर्शनमय करे।
कहीं अन्यते
मारु जरी परमाणु मात्र। के साथ में जो
शरीर है ना वो भी मेरा नहीं। एक रजकण भी मेरा
नहीं। फिर पराई चीज
के लेकर के मैं क्या करूँगा? वो मिलेगी छूट
जाएगी। फायदा क्या? जाए
फायदा क्या? कितना भी दे दो पूरी दुनिया मेरे कदमों में गिरे
लेकिन फिर भी मेरे परमात्मा से बढ़ पर नहीं है
क्योंकि मिलेगी वो बिछड़ जाएगी। शाश्वत रहने वाली
मुझे शाश्वत परमात्मा मिल गया और मैं दुखी कहाँ हूँ?
परमात्मा के दर्शन से मैं दुखी कहाँ हूँ? मेरे दुख तो सब मिट गए।
मैं इसीलिए कुछ चाहता था सुखी होने के लिए।
मैं परब्रह्म के ऊपर नज़र... मैं परपदार्थों को नज़र क्यों डालता था?
वो मिल जाए ऐसी कामना क्यों रखता था? सुखी होने की।
लेकिन बिना कुछ मिले भी
मुझे मेरे परमात्मा से अनंत शांति मिल रही है। अब मुझे किसी चीज़ का कोई प्रयोजन रहा?
मुझे कोई प्रयोजन उल्टा उपाधि है संभालने की। मुझे नहीं चाहिए इन्द्रासन।
चक्रवर्ती की संपदा
और इन्द्रशरीर। संपदा और इंद्रसरीखे दो कागुविठ संगिनत है
सम्यक दृष्टि लो नहीं चाहिए। नहीं लेकिन हम आपसे प्रसन्न हो गए हैं ले लो ना।
क्या आपके घर में जगह नहीं है जो कचरा मेरे को देते हो? क्या समझते हैं?
कि आपके घर का कचरा मेरे को
मत देना मैं सुअर हूँ। कचरा
समझते हैं। अधिक पुण्य और विष्ठा का बड़ा ढेर है सौगानी। विष्टा का
बड़ा धेर है सौगानी जी के वचन अधिक पुण्य
उसकी साहिबी ये क्या है? ये विष्टा का बड़ा धेर है क्या करें उसको रख कर के क्या करें?
कि नहीं नहीं आपको बड़ा fridge देंगे 300 liter वाला।
इतनी बड़ी imp वाला Mercedes car देंगे लेकिन भैया garage कौन देगा?
क्या? और driver के पैसे कौन देगा? नहीं चाहिए आप
Mercedes रखो आपके पास। देखो। इसके बाद... नहीं इसके बदले पैसा दे दो
आधे पैसे नहीं Mercedes लेना पड़े। क्या gift लगती है Mercedes की Maruti car।
झोपड़ी पट्टी में रहने वाले को Maruti car gift में
battery लग जाती है अब क्या होता है।
परेशानी है। नहीं अभी
Maruti car रखने की जगह नहीं है भैया तुम इसका पैसा दे दो ना।
पैसा तो अभी काम है।
Maruti car ही लेना पड़ेगा। क्या हुआ है। क्या हुआ है इसको अच्छा लगता है?
अब तो ऐसा लड्डू आ गया इधर नीचे उतरता ना बाहर निकलता है।
क्या मना भी नहीं कर सकता और लिए तो परेशानी बात ही है।
ऐसी हालत है ये। लड्डू इधर फंस गया है ना निकलता है ना बाहर निकलता
है। ऐसा अटक गया है कुछ हो नहीं।
कि Mercedes लेके जाओ लेकिन फिर Mercedes को बाहर निकालना मुसीबत है।
थोड़ा उचटका लग जाएगा तो।
इसके बाद... हो जाएगा तो।
इसके। फिर driver भी ऐसा चाहिए वो ₹2000 तनख्वाह वाला driver
नहीं चाहिए Mercedes वाले। वो
driver ही महंगा आता है उसका। Mercedes
का driver अलग रहता है। फिर garage भी अच्छा होना पड़ेगा।
तो अपने पूर्व स्नान कराते हैं ना अभी Mercedes पूर्व
स्नान कराना पड़ेगा। साबुन से अच्छा
रगड़ना पड़ेगा। क्योंकि Mercedes है भैया।
ऐसी उपाधि हजामत हो जाएगी फिर। क्या कहते हैं?
क्या विश्व में अब और कुछ चाहना बाकी रह गई? क्या चाहोगे
आप? कुछ नहीं
चाहूंगा। एक रजकंडीन को नहीं चाहूंगा।
पराई चीज को
लेकर के क्या करूँ? संभालूँगा, वापस देने का ही है।
कि नहीं, मैं बाहर गाँव जा रहा हूँ, मेरा ₹1,00,000 आपके पास संभालना
है। खुशी-खुशी लेता है कि दुखी होकर के लेता है?
बताइए। रहते हैं तिजोरी में। रहते हैं तिजोरी में, अपनी तिजोरी में रखता है।
लेकिन नज़र करते ही मेरापन का भाव आता है। Use कर सकता है।
न जाने कब मांग ले।
उल्टा संभालने का बोझ है कि कोई अपनी तिजोरी चोर तोड़ा ना, चोर।
और पैसे हैं तो किसके ऊपर आता है ये सब?
ये अच्छा लगता है पराई चीज़ को रखना अपने पास? नहीं भई
पैसा bank में मेरे को... पैसा bank में रखो मेरे को। क्योंकि मैं यहाँ हूँ नहीं
हूँ फिर
किसी को मालूम हो नहीं हो।
पैसे का मामला नहीं। क्यों इतना? बहुत मजबूरी से बहुत close relation है तो रखना
पड़ता है बाकी रखने का... देखो।
दागिने हो, जेवर रखो, पैसे हो। ऐसे ना नहीं रखते हैं। बोझा लगता है।
अगर रखना पड़ा तो भी क्या लगता है?
बोझा लगता है, संभालने की चिंता। जिसको परमात्मा मिल गया उसको... जिसको
परमात्मा मिल गया उसको इतना भी खोजा चाहिए।
शरीर खोजा रूप लगता है। तो परिग्रह कहाँ से अच्छा लगेगा? अच्छा नहीं लगता
है। चिन्ह मूरत द्रग दारीखी।
मोय रीति लगत है। फटाफटे। बार नारकी कुति दुख भोगे।
अंतर सुख रस। फटाफटे। नहीं कुछ नहीं चाहिए
कुछ देओ तो खोजा पड़ेगा। कोजा पड़ेगा। पुण्य के उदय से
मिलता तो है लेकिन इतना कोजा पड़ता है?
अच्छा नहीं सुहा तो नहीं है। सुविधा सुविधा सुविधा सुविधा में जीना नहीं चाहता है।
फिर testing कब करेगा? मुझे चैतन्य परमात्मा मिल गया।
testing जो होती है वो तो किसमें होती है?
प्रतिकूलता में होती है। प्रतिकूलता आवे तो ज्ञान जागृत होता है। fight करने
का एक लड़ाई करने का अवसर होता है। खिलाओ
पिलाओ और फिर कुश्ती मत कराओ। पिलाओ और फिर कुश्ती मत कराओ अभी क्या होगा
पहलवान भी चूहा बन जाएगा।
क्या? लड़ने को काम आएगा लेकिन अभी खिलाओ पिलाओ अच्छा।
बादाम पिस्ता काजू दूध दूध सब। 1 kilo सब्जी चबा दो
ऐसा। अच्छा पिला करके उसको सुधा दो भाई। क्या? चूहा भी मार के जाएगा उसको।
क्योंकि वो काम तो करता नहीं है। Testing नहीं होती
है। ऐसा सुख ज्ञानी को नहीं चाहिए उसको तो पल पल में तकलीफ चाहिए। ताकि
वो अपने ज्ञान को करते रहे।
रोज थोड़ा थोड़ा practice चलती रहे। तो अच्छा लगता है।
ये तो गर्मी पड़ी है तो भैया AC room AC room में बिठा दो। क्या होगा?
कि 2-4 घंटा दोपहर के time में
थोड़ी गर्मी सहन करने दो ना
उसको। क्या है देखो तो सही वो ज्ञान के कैसा। कितनी tempering
होती है मालूम पड़ जाएगा कितना ओइमा ओइमा करता है।
नहीं नहीं हम उसको मौका नहीं देंगे रे। हमारे
से। उसको मौका नहीं देंगे। हमारे से आगे निकल जाए कैसे होगा?
क्या?
हमको आगे जाना है। गुरु को तो यहाँ बिठाओ। आप रोज प्रवचन देना, diary check करना।
आप मेरी उम्र भी आपको लग जाए। अच्छा।
क्या? क्या? क्योंकि फिर ऐसा
कहाँ मिलेगा ये सब? Packing करने वाला।
आप फिरें और सबको तारें। अच्छा।
इसलिए आप यहीं बैठे रहें।
बूढ़े हो जाओ तो भी यहीं बैठे, कमर दुख जाए तो भी। टूटे हो जाओ तो भी यहीं बैठे
कमर दुख जाए तो भी बैठे रहना।
और हमको जल्दी-जल्दी भेज दो उधर। मोक्ष।
ये सब उल्टी मामला है। तो गुरु जी देख रहे
हैं केवल ज्ञान। केवल ज्ञान को। मैं मर जाऊंगा किधर ऐसा। मेरे को केवल ज्ञान हो गया और
मेरे को मैं उनको देख रहा हूं तो मेरे को केवल ज्ञान। मेरे को ख्याल रखो
मेरा क्या होगा। ऐसे सपने तो
मरते। ऐसे सपने तो मत देखो दिन में।
दिन में सपने देखते ऐसा। मेरे को केवल ज्ञान हो
गया और गुरुजी देख रहे हैं। लटका दिए
ना आपके मेरे को।
नहीं आप diary check करो उधर और भी आते नए नए।
फस गई मुर्गी फस गई बाहर बने से। आपको पहली बार बता रहे हैं। दरवाजे पे खड़े हो।
ना अंदर ना बाहर। पिकड़े रहो ना अंदर ना बाहर।
क्या उसकी तो बहुत परेशानी हो जाती है, हजामत हो जाती है, मारा
जाता है। आप ही बोलते थे गुरु
दरवाजे पे खड़े रहते हैं, भैया कितने बोला मुझे गुरु
बोलना है। बेकार के
चढ़ा दिए छपरे पे। क्या विश्व में
अब और भी कुछ चाहना बाकी रह गई
परमात्मा मिलने के बाद? तो कैसी है
परमात्मा कैसा है? अरे... परमात्मा कैसा है? अरे निरिच्छुक वस्तु।
क्या बोलते हैं परमात्मा को?
कि तू मिल जाए तो सारी दुनिया की इच्छा खत्म हो जाती है। तो तू कैसा है?
वो चैतन्य चिंतामणि है। वो वो जड़ चिंतामणि रत्न रहता है।
क्या?
तो उसको तो मांगना पड़ता है ये दो वो दो वो
दो देता है वो बिना चिंतन करे नहीं मिलता है वो।
एक कल्पवृक्ष, एक कामधेनु गाय, और एक चिंतामणि रत्न और ये कैसा है?
ये ऐसा रत्न है कि बिना मांगे मिले। क्या? मांगना नहीं है। निरीक्षित वस्तु।
आपकी इच्छा को ही खत्म कर दे।
इच्छा करो और पदार्थ मिले और बिछड़े तो रोना, काहे की बात है? जड़ मुँह से काट ही दो।
ये परमात्मा कैसा है? निरीक्षित वस्तु है।
कि उसके दर्शन होंगे तो कोई इच्छा बाकी रहेगी? ये
चाहिए वो चाहिए ऐसा नहीं रोना। देखो ये नया word दिया आत्मा को।
आत्मा कैसा? सौगानी जी के पास नए-नए शब्द हैं, ये अपन पहले भी लिए थे, निर्बाध,
सफराधीन, चैतन्य। हैं? शब्द गौर करें तो मालूम पड़ेगा।
क्या अनादि, अनंत ये तो सब common word हैं, अजर, अमर ये सब। अभेद,
ज्ञानमूर्ति, चैतन्यमूर्ति ये उनके अलग ही शब्द हैं। निरीक्षित वस्तु,
आत्मा कैसा? आत्मा का दूसरा नाम क्या? निरीक्षित वस्तु। निरीक्षित
वस्तु। कि अगर दर्शन हो जाएंगे तो एक भी इच्छा बाकी नहीं रहेगी। निरीक्षित वस्तु।
और ये निरीक्षित वस्तु। राग रहित।
मतलब करना धरना से मुक्त सिर्फ जाननी देखनी। मतलब वितराग अवस्था।
राग रहित माने वितरागता सहित।
करूँ नहीं करूँ हट गया पर जानूँ देखूँ रह गया। तो राग रहित
वितरागता सहित। वित्राक्त सहित अतींद्रिय।
ये 5 इंद्रियों का व्यापार का काम जरूरत नहीं है आँख कान नाक आदि।
अतींद्रिय आनंद का अपूर्व स्वाद।
ये आँखों से गाना सुनते हैं तो आनंद आता है ऐसा आनंद नहीं है।
कुछ देखते हैं आँख से और आनंद आता है ऐसा आनंद नहीं है।
पंच इंद्रियों से जो आनंद मिलता है वो आनंद तो जड़ का स्वाद है।
वो real में आनंद है ही नहीं। ये
अतींद्रिय बिना इंद्रियों के। अतींद्रिय बिना इंद्रियों के आधार रखे हुए अंदर का
आत्मिक आनंद मिलता है। जो अतींद्रिय आनंद है।
उसका कैसा स्वाद? अपूर्व। अपूर्व स्वाद, पहले कभी ऐसा स्वाद चखा नहीं।
अपूर्व सहज ज्ञान कला।
ऐसा तो पता ही नहीं था, हम तो शास्त्र पढ़ते थे, उपवास करते थे, माला फेरते थे।
नमस्कार मंत्र का जाप करते थे,
भगवान के दर्शन अभिषेक पूजा करते थे। और कितना... कितना बोझा था सर पे
ये करूँ वो करूँ ऐसा करूँ वैसा करूँ। ये तो कैसी
कला है? सहज automatic होने वाली ज्ञान कला है।
इसमें करना नहीं करना रहता ही नहीं। जाप भी जपना नहीं
एक भी। नमस्कार मंत्र का एक शब्द भी बोलना नहीं।
क्या ये खाओ ये नहीं खाओ उपवास उपवास कुछ नहीं
माला फला कुछ नहीं। प्रतिगमन नहीं प्रत्याख्यान नहीं पूजा भक्ति कुछ
नहीं। क्या
सहज ज्ञान कलाम? जानना जानना जानना
जानना। अरे निरीक्षित वस्तु दाग रहित अतींद्रिय आनंद का
अपूर्व स्वाद अपूर्व सहज ज्ञान कलाम। आश्चर्य हो exclamation mark दिया है। ऐसा
रहेगा। भाव भाव से
रहेगा इतना गोल। इतना बोलकर इतनी जबरदस्त बातें इसमें आई कि
पहले का
अर्थ। मैं
पढ़ लेता हूँ
वापस। अरे भगवान कारुण परमात्मा,
तेरे दर्शन होते ही विभाव की पीठ दिखने लगती है।
तेरा यथार्थ ज्ञान हुए बिना पूर्व में... पूर्व में
परिणाम आश्रित परिणामों का इतना तीव्र बंद कर चुका था
कि उनकी अवधि खत्म होने के लिए तेरे दर्शन स्वाभाविक होने ही थे।
अरे चैतन्य तेरी इतनी पौलाई विस्मित सा कर देती है।
हे गुरुदेव आप कितनी पौलाई तक प्रसर चुके हो पौलाई।
चुके हो। पउलाई भी है और साथ में ठोस पना भी। हे गुरुदेव,
आपकी वाणी का स्पर्श होते ही
मानव विश्व की उत्तमोत्तम वस्तु की प्राप्ति हो गई।
उत्तम नहीं, उत्तम से भी उत्तम। क्या मैं मुक्त होने वाला हूँ? यकीन नहीं आ रहा है?
क्या मैं मुक्त होने वाला हूँ? अरे,
शास्त्रों में जिस मुक्ति की इतनी महिमा वखानी है, उसे
आपके... उसे आपके शब्द मात्रा ने इतना सरल कर दिया। क्या विश्व में
अब और भी कुछ चाहना बाकी रह गई? Question.
नहीं रही। अरे निश्चित वस्तु राग रहित
अतिंद्रिय आनंद का अपूर्व
स्वाद। अपूर्व सहज ज्ञान कला। यहाँ तक अपन ले आए।
Time अभी... हो गया।
हो। हो गया।
अभी लेना है। अच्छा। चलो
अभी यहीं खत्म करते